i get hate over the years i've gotten
probably a lot of hate and i don't care
because usually the more hate i get the
more money i'm making um and you need
that hate like you like if you don't
want to go for it but if you are marking
yourself and you're polarizing and
you're getting tons and tons of
attention and tons of people are
connecting with you some people are
gonna are gonna like get pushed the
wrong way and you're gonna get some hate
so i actually have found that like
you're doing things right you're sucking
people in and you're pushing people away
you're putting your flags up and you're
saying this is who i am this is what i
want this is what who i don't want but
the the only hate that bothers me is
that like oh greg got inheritance uh he
couldn't have started his business
without his without like you know this
and that oh like yep he just had the
reality is that i started my business
lean the first year cost me 500
and that first year i made 10 grand and
i i saved it and i and then the next
year i i made thirty thousand dollars
and i and i saved that and the next year
i made eighty thousand and then the
fourth fourth year i made 200k
and then the fifth year i made a million
dollars before i spent one dollar on
advertising literally and i barely had
employees i had two people working for
me that i i i gave them a little bit of
a profit split at the time and so like i
i did it lean i wasn't like i wasn't
like oh i need to get 100k or 200k to
start this business and i need to do
this and i i'm gonna run in the hole i
actually built my company on on uh
doing organic blog content youtube
content building my own mailing list
like literally had no expenses and then
and then i only started spending
lots of money on ads when i already when
i was already making a million plus a
year and then that's when things kind of
started to kind of escalate a lot but
then people are like oh you know he must
have had he must have got millions of
dollars and then invested on starting
his business and hiring this marketing
team and then doing that it's like no i
started like i even the real start was
when i was like
working out and reading all kinds of
fitness stuff
yeah there's no overnight successes
every overnight success i know of took
five ten years to achieve that success
it's not as easy and i'm like you to the
point of haters and you know those of
you that are watching me for a while
i've heard me say this before but i'll
say it again hate only ever comes from
beneath nobody ever gets jealous of
losers right so whenever somebody's
spewing hate at you it's usually envy uh
envy driven right because you're either
you look better than them you make more
money than them your girl's hotter than
them you're driving nicer car it's like
it doesn't matter what it is it's
usually envy driven right
oh yeah no 100 and also i mean here's
what here's what here's what i'll say
and i'll say that
the more haters the better like if the
world is full of haters
that the
it is a lot easier to succeed
because there's no one whose mental
model is is is dialed in more for
failure than a hater um eckhart tolle
has this really powerful quote and i see
it i see it so much and it's that
it's that whenever you resent someone
else's success
you curtail your own success if you want
to attract and welcome success
um if you want to attract a success you
have to welcome it wherever you see it
you know when i saw tai lopez in in uh
2015 popping off okay when i saw todd
lopez in 2015 popping off was that a
dinner and that you know and it was this
mixed bag of more fitness figures that
were making money in the industry um and
and i think some of them had definitely
achieved some good success
but
every all of them kind of
crashed and burned um at this dinner
like they pretty much all maybe a couple
are still doing okay but but they were
just going on this freaking they're just
hating on tai lopez all this guy
well what a douche bag he's you know
he's got this rented lamborghini and his
garage video and they're hating on
hating on hating on it
and i was like and i didn't even know
who he was at the time i'm like who's
this tai lopez guy and and i found the
video and i was like this guy's a
[ __ ] genius
holy cow and i'm like like i'm seeing
these ads everywhere okay this guy is
clearly making tons of money from these
ads you can't spend this much amount on
youtube if if you're losing money
install i always get curious when i see
[ __ ] like that i'm like what's this guy
doing that i'm not doing i know i got
curious and i was like i got pissed off
i'm like why am i not running ads i'm
like this guy's running i'm like i can
make a cooler ad and that's why i kind
of made that bruce wayne video and then
that did very well for us but like see
that's the problem see once you start
hating you stop learning
and and and so if someone's above you
and you start hating on them oh look how
they're they're using a lamborghini to
market themselves or in their garage or
you know it's like then that you've
thrown away that learning opportunity
and
again i will say this the more haters in
the world the easier it is for me to
succeed because you're you're literally
you're literally attaching a you know an
iron to yourself you're you're you're
attaching a chain and ball to yourself
um and again i was going through life
just hating on hating on people it just
throws you down down so i don't care
like i don't care if even if someone is
even if someone is putting themselves
out there in sort of a bad way but
they're they're they're usually there's
something to learn from you know so you
don't have to love everything they're
doing there's there's something to learn
from you know even even look at look at
uh look at the past president you know
i mean he he did an amazing job at it
but even even like a lot of people
talking about him today they still hate
him on them too but like you can't even
people like they that's an extreme
example if you can't they're like free
marketing i always look at haters like
that's my free marketing team they won't
shut up about me thank you
no 100
100 and i've always kind of had this
little belief that like basically no one
is inherently all good no one inherently
is all bad and you know stupid people
just kind of they kind of live in
extremes where oh he's terrible and
everything he does is bad doesn't have
one good quality um whereas the truth is
always sort of in the middle like
there's people are double-edged swords
no matter how amazing or terrible
someone is they have you know different
qualities and if you you can't see that
then you're going through life blind if
you can't see that you know
that this person who's a very uh heated
or controversial figure
has both sides and he's doing good
things too or he's doing or this amazing
you know if you can't see that you're
going through life blind and like um
no one should listen to you because you
you have no objectivity
you